relâché les épaules
relâchées la mâchoire inférieure
c'est votre visage
et connectez-vous à votre respiration à
chaque début de cours johanna invite ses
élèves à lâcher prise pour réaliser au
mieux leurs séances de yoga vinyasa
depuis une dizaine d'années cette
versaillaise pratiquer cette discipline
développés au cours du 20e siècle c'est
un gars qu'on pratique en musique
souvent qui est un petit peu plus
dynamique puisque en fait on enchaîne
les postures au rythme de la respiration
donc on va les tenir un peu moins
longtemps que dans une séance classique
de hatha yoga mais on va en faire plus
et on va demander un petit peu plus
d'engagement physique
vous l'aurez compris malgré l'ambiance
tamisée relaxante les cinq élèves
présents ce jour là vont transpirer
après un échauffement de dix minutes ils
enchaînent les postures en rythme avec
leur respiration saignée des allers
retours ça de bien dissocier chaque
partie
expirez arrondissez on encore si le
milieu le haut du don pousse sur ses
mains ces exercices ont pour but de
solliciter les muscles profonds les
muscles profonds c'est tout ce qu'ils
permettent de soutenir le squelette on
pense souvent aux trans vertes qui sont
les muscles du ventre plat au psoas
aussi qui peut être en cause dans les
mal de dos quand il n'est pas assez tiré
c'est le muscle qui relie la le fémur au
dos et ensuite on travaille aussi la
force
les bras on travaille aussi la souplesse
et les équilibres après une heure la
séance semble avoir porté ses fruits
c'est pas impressionnant peut-être comme
ça mais ça permet de travailler
l'équilibré les muscles profonds et
quelque chose qui est assez sportif ou
moi j'avais beaucoup sous-estimé je
pensais que c'était facile et au final
pas du tout par exemple je fais de la
musculation à côté et maintenant j'avais
beaucoup mieux à passer tout ce qui est
pompée on a vraiment renforcé même le
haut du corps et j'ai vraiment raffermit
à ma sangle abdominale ce que je pensais
pas du tout selon joanna cette
discipline est accessible à tous la
professeure conseille de faire une à
deux séances par semaine pour pouvoir
sculpté à la fois son corps et son
esprit si vous voulez tester le forfait
de 140 euros pour cinq cours